TIMOTHY JORDAN:
And now it's time
to talk about Android Auto.
Doesn't it feel like old times?
SPEAKER 1: I know
it feels like we're
in an introduction to
Android Auto reunion.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Dylan, tell us
about what we're sitting in?
Actually, before we
get to that, tell me
about what the latest
is with Android Auto.
SPEAKER 2: Well, I think, the
latest we're showing here today
is that Android is now
embeddable in the car.
So unlike, I think,
we've seen in the past,
you guys were
showing on the phone
or even connected over USB to
the car that's Android Auto,
now we're showing Android as
the actual embedded operating
system in the car.
So our goal is always to have
safe, seamless, integrated,
connected services.
And now, I think, we're seeing
the seamless part of that.
There's no phone involved here.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
And It's beautiful.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
So this is an Audi
Q8 concept car.
It's absolutely gorgeous,
it's got a really nice set
of screens we can look at here.
And Audi actually just announced
plans to ship, in the future,
with Android in the car.
So that's what we're
showing here today.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Very cool.
Well, let's get to, I don't
know, play with some features.
And then we'll get back to
Android Auto, in general.
SPEAKER 2: Cool, all right.
Well, let me show you a
few different things here.
So first of all, we've
obviously got a home screen,
doesn't really look like a
phone, doesn't look a wearable,
or TV.
So this is nice automotive,
integrated experience.
We've got the kind
of information
a driver is used to seeing here.
But the key aspect to this is
that Audi did the integration
and it's Audi's UI concept.
It's not just another phone
or even just another car.
So, for example, they like to
have music front and center.
They've got a
great sound system,
so there's interactive
tiles here.
We can turn these on and off.
They have the ability to
look at vehicle information.
Unfortunately, we're
not driving right now,
so it's a little static.
But they have this and
it's an Android app.
That's the important part,
it's just an Android app.
We can also go to the home
screen and see on the launcher,
they've got their
important stuff
that they feel is
front and center here.
So for example, we can
switch between apps,
there's an Audi navigation app.
And we can start
running it, does
what you might expect in a car.
We're driving somewhere
, so that's good.
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE] good.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
Oh, let's not.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: We should,
right through those doors there.
SPEAKER 2: Actually,
yeah, we should do.
Not.
They won't be happy.
Yes.
So this is happening, but what I
want to draw your attention to,
actually, is the
integrated aspect of--
what's important here is
over in the cluster display
now which actually
isn't running Android,
this is a real-time
operating system
for the driver information.
But we do have
information coming
from the app, from the APK,
through the vehicle network,
and it's being integrated
into their cluster over here.
The same with, actually, the
Android notifications as well.
And if I switch
to what they call
their Big Stage,
their different view,
we can also now push
through a cluster API.
We can push real graphics
from an app as well.
So this is a pretty
automotive specific,
this is not something
you would necessarily
want to do on a watch
or what have you.
But this is the
kind of integration
we're looking to do
with the partners.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome
how it's all well integrated.
And you still get the real-time
OS for the instrumentation.
That I imagine is critical
in the automotive industry.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah, absolutely.
So we're really focusing on
what they call infotainment.
The music, the maps, the
media, the car information.
But what we're not going into is
the critical information that--
we're not touching the
brakes, for example.
We're not controlling
the brakes, yet.
I shouldn't say yet, we're
not controlling the brakes.
Or things like the
speed limit which
really has to be accurate
and present all the time.
But, I think, the
key, as we're saying,
is we still want to show
integration as appropriate.
So the driver has
all the information
they need to see right
in front of their eyes.
And the passenger, for example,
can still work with the system
as well.
So let's switch to
Google Maps, for example.
Like this.
And the passenger can work
with the app, like so,
or they can even use the Google
services like the assistant.
Navigate to San Francisco.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: San
Francisco, all right.
SPEAKER 2: That's more
like it, we're on the way.
We can also show how here we've
got third party apps as well.
So we were just
talking about how
on the phone side of
things, the app developers
have enabled their apps to
work seamlessly in a car.
And the same applies here.
So it just extends right
across the ecosystem
as just another screen
to an app developer
implementing a couple of APIs.
But of course we can
switch to different apps.
And, I think, the
really cool thing here
is that it still looks
and feels like an Audi.
It feels like a
premium experience,
but it also feels
like Pocket Casts.
And it also feels like Spotify.
So, I think, those
are the key things
we're trying to call out
with this concept demo
with Audi is number one, Android
is a good operating system
for the car.
Number two, the developer
ecosystem can come with it
and tie really nicely
with a good vehicle
integration as well.
So there's--
SPEAKER 1: It sounds like it
uses the standard Android Auto
media and messaging
API so that just--
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: --integrates
right in here.
So yeah, that's cool.
SPEAKER 2: Yep, absolutely.
Like Media Browse,
Media Session--
as long as the apps
work there then
Audi can assure that it's going
to work in there car, as can
any other OEMs as well.
So that's the key,
the standard APIs.
SPEAKER 1: Nice.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Well, before we
get going, I'd like
to ask what else is going on
in the world of Android Auto?
One of the things that
I noticed recently,
and people are
still asking about,
is that you can get
Android Auto on your phone
even if your car doesn't have
the integration built in.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah, yeah.
So one of the
things we talk about
is safe and seamless connected
experience in any car.
So obviously in this
car we have it here,
it's seamless, connected.
But actually just if
I have a phone when
I'm driving my crummy, old--
I shouldn't say crummy.
My Mazda 5.
I love it.
I love it, it moves
my kids around.
I can stick this
on the dashboard,
I have Bluetooth connection, and
I have everything that I want.
So if I'm driving
with my old car that
doesn't have Android
Auto into it,
I can still use my phone, as
is, and look at the media apps
that I already use today--
my contacts and my map
in a safe seamless way.
So, yeah, I think,
that's the exciting part
is on the phone connected
from the phone to the car.
Or just the car.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Very cool.
SPEAKER 2: There you go.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Well, I think, that's
all the time that we have.
So, I guess, we'll get going.
Anything else you want to say?
SPEAKER 2: If we're going to
get going we should just drive.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Yeah, let's do that.
SPEAKER 1: Let's do it.